the luxury watch fair in Geneva or sih H
for short is one of the most prestigious
in the business taught brands like
Cartier present their latest treasures
but not just to any one only selected
journalists and industry insiders are
welcome the watch making field has
traditionally been secretive and elitist
but that starting to change
watch bloggers like on each plot are
opening up this exclusive world to all
timepiece connoisseurs everyone around
the world that that is is looking to see
what's happening can see instantly all
the novelties all the new pieces that
get hands on get videos get opinions in
something which is instantaneous you
know it's it was unheard of probably
five years ago it's 9:00 in the morning
in Geneva an outdoor photoshoot all in
white Mott and his team are taking
pictures of new models by a German
watchmaker with the world premiere
tomorrow at the trade fair the British
vlogger will be treating his readers to
an exclusive preview Locke has 1.5
million Instagram followers making him
the undisputed king of digital watch
writers no other blogger presents
watches solar labyrinth Lee and
extravagantly the 34 year olds visual
language stands out and what's still a
conservative watch scene
I tried to show like my tastes through
the pictures and the content that we
make you know because I love watches but
I also love to travel I like nice
restaurants I like cigars I like to
drink you know nice nice cognac sand and
and fine wine and things like this so
it's all of these kind of things
together BOTS blog has been up and
running since 2012
watch honest has seen its fanbase grow
steadily his influence in the watch
industry has grown too but bots is not
the only influential blogger worn and
wound in the United States and watched
by sjx and Singapore that also make or
break a new model the watch industry is
only slowly waking up to this fact
change is not something that they do
very easily so I think they're afraid
but I think now they see that they can't
really ignore it anymore because it's
it's knocking at their door every single
day and there and consumers are the ones
that are coming to them it's now late
afternoon in Geneva and final
preparations for the trade fair are
being made one manufacturer that
understood the influence of the
blogosphere sometime ago is row J Dubuis
it invited bloggers to view its newest
creations even before the show opened a
shrewd move because consulting firm
Deloitte reports that social media are
the most important marketing tool and
the watchmaking industry when you have a
customer who tell us we have been seeing
on watch a niche this type of few models
can you show it to us so our barometer
is very easy that we have dealers we
have about 160 dealers in the world plus
25 stores and as soon as you start to
speak with them in details on if
possible with good words about what we
are doing the effect is immediate on
customers coming to our stores
in the watchmaking field classic print
advertising and glossy industry
magazines used to be the most important
means of communication but blogs and
social media
now provide companies with rapid
feedback from customers
Marni's bot has a 300,000 euro a year
consultant contract with manufacturers
he also gets little gifts like this
but bot says he can't just bow
uncritically to everything they make or
his blog would soon lose its followers
do you dilute and you've become too
commercial or you start talking about
things that really you know are not good
products or you know in your heart is
not something that you would talk about
but you do it for money eventually your
audience will see that you know your
audience are not stupid because they
connect with you because they they know
you they know your taste that's why they
follow you and so he continues to cater
to those followers by seeking and rating
the most expensive rare and extravagant
watches out there and photographing them
in equally stylish settings